thank you all coming for my session I
really appreciate for you taking the
time to attend this session I know
there's other parallel tracks happening
and I I really don't take it for granted
so my name is hunga hunga I'm Linda and
I'm here to talk about distributed
tracing so just a about be Who I am
originally from Nairobi Kenya that's why
I'm best so thank you to Alex and the
team for making it happen
I walk on infrastructure at a company
called as you--as adju is basically a
custom and analytics company and I've
spent maybe two or three years building
data pipelines and monitoring or just
observing they had data pipelines so
this is basically a very introductory
talk we'll have some code snippets at
the end and some demos but if anyone is
really experienced or running
distributed tracing I don't think you'll
benefit much out of this talk but for
anyone who's here for introductory
material this is perfect for you and if
you're here and you decide to stay and
you experience um please hold me
accountable if I say anything that is a
lie and just feel free to shout out
right cool okay so at the end of this
talk I just hope that you know you're
able to pick up one or two things that
you can take back to you company or or
your team and incorporate that into
whatever you're doing and how I want you
to use this talk is just don't take
everything literal don't just blindly
follow nano software is like that and
software is about trade off so it's just
about preferences things I might talk
about here that you probably wouldn't do
and these things that you might want to
talk about that I probably wouldn't do
so and there's a lot lots of ways of
doing things so what I would encourage
is to try this within your team and
because you probably know most of the
context within your team you understand
the domain and trying out things will
probably be more helpful than blindly
following what I'm trying to say
okay with that being said let's get
started so just a bit of history the
last maybe decade we've spent you know
building monolithic applications and
we've witnessed a change in shift on how
we do that or how we deployed internet
scale applications over the last few
years so historically we did to the
single single process implemented as a
single runtime deployment was just you
know single language probably lamp stack
most of a time and it was I mean it was
grateful for quite a while right it was
easy straight up
but then scaling monoliths were become
increasing ly hard as as we go it became
tedious and painful one reason as teams
grow most of it a big team contributing
to one single repository changes
basically it's a pain right deployments
are all or nothing a deployment is
basically a day where you just stand off
everything so that we can deploy that
right so this this is really painful and
the industry we started moving away from
deploying applications as monoliths to
micro services because of Ava scaling
organizations or scaling teams or so we
moved into this other architecture so
distributed systems and this was really
pushed by container technologies and
cloud computing and now you can be
easily deploy services to multiple
clouds you can do on trim and on cloud
at the same time teams can be using
tools that they actually enjoy doing so
a data science team would write a
recommendation engine in Python or Scala
and you know up another team would write
maybe an API get to with nod so teams
get to use what they actually enjoy and
would be the best tool for the job and
by adopting micro-services organizations
who are ripping or ripping a lot of
benefits from better scale abilities of
components to higher developer
productivity but despite the benefits
and egg adoption of from companies large
and small micro services come with their
own challenges and complexities so an
example would be so suppose we have 20
components in in an application and all
of them require I required to produce a
response on a single request when we ran
in a monolith or failure modes are
restricted to bugs potential crashes and
you can basically disease logging to get
an idea of what's happening but if you
run the same components as microservices
on different hosts separated by networks
we introduced many more potential
failure points from network hiccups to
resource constraints right so observing
such a system drastically drastically
reduces if we try to use traditional
monitoring tools so this is you know
metrics and and logs because you can
only so with micro services you know new
challenges are introduced and it's a
trade-off for one set of organizational
and technology problems for others now
you have to think about deployment
packaging and configuration management
to debugging and secret management but
in this talk we're just going to focus
on a small bit of observability which is
tracing right ok so it is much harder
for teams to understand exactly what
happened when you using distributed
systems because a single request tends
to go through multiple servers before
it's being served back and while the
benefits amount well the benefits of
that you know key organizational
boundaries a division of labor created
agility there's some
a lot of costs that come with that right
and traditional monitoring tools are
very ill equipped in trying to to
observe that they might tell a story for
from a single instance but again a
request will touch multiple servers
before you know having the request or
responding back to the request and a
single instance is not enough to to give
you context of what's happening and in a
monolith troubleshooting that would just
you know isolate an instance reproduce a
problem and you're good to go right and
with micro services this approach is no
longer feasible because no single
service provides a complete picture of
the performance and how their how the
application is supposed to be guess were
working and that's where distributed
tracing comes into play so what is
distributed tracing distributed tracing
is about understanding the path of data
as it propagates through components in
application in a nutshell the tracing
infrastructure attaches contextual
metadata to each request and ensures
that the metadata is passed around
during the request execution right and
capturing these traces allows you to
build the view of an entire chain of
calls behind the user interaction and
that simple technique allows the tracing
infrastructure to reconstruct the whole
path of a request from when the request
feeds the server to actually getting
back a response so that's the basic
basically how distributed tracing works
right and in order for us to discuss the
concepts of how distributed tracing
works we need to define some common
nomenclature that and explained the UNAM
anatomy of address so a choice follows a
request of a system event from its
source to the ultimate destination and
if you hitting 20 micro services and
each service is generating a spun
combination of all those ones you
what we call a trace yeah and each trace
is an each trace is a narrative that
tells the story of a request at it as it
as it travels through the system next we
want to look at what's inside a trace
which is a span and a span is the
primary component within represents an
individual unit of work done in a
distributed systems system spans are
generally named and have a start time
and an end time I don't know if I
captured that off Northern Ireland and
its finest and both with a unique ID as
well as the idea of the tress and the ID
of the parent spawn and all this
correlation that is propagated
downstream and the reported out of bound
and to a distributed engine so most of
the available distributed tracing
engines I think use the UDP to report
the data out of bond so this does not
affect your application at all and this
feature of distributed tracing makes it
possible to correlate data across
processes together and figure out
exactly where something went wrong
yeah and at the top spun a is what we
call the routes one it's a fast spun in
the tress and usually the duration is
approximately how long the tress took to
go through out through from the first
time it hits the server to when you get
a response next we have context
propagation now distributed tracing
wouldn't work without context
propagation and context propagation is
basically or tracing doesn't work
without context propagation typically
because a distributed trace traverses
more than one service unique and passes
information from one service to the next
one this could be through headers or in
other forms so metadata propagation is
probably the most popular
way of of doing that these other ways
that have been documented I think
Facebook and cannot be do it differently
but metadata propagation is probably the
most common yeah so so the data is
carried along side the business requests
as part of the headers that move from in
this example it would be when the first
type the first time they request hits or
service we first extract the headers and
check for tress ID the parent ID and
this one ID tress ID and this one ID if
they're available and if a service
another service had send this request
with this information then it will just
be a continuous stress but if it's the
first time then we have to generate this
information if it's not available right
so we try extract the headers if we
don't find any trace headers then we
generate a tress ID a span ID and a
parent ID since this is basically the
routes one if you manage to get trusted
as then the incoming requests would
extract the Tres ID parent ID and any
other baggage information that we might
want to propagate downstream and when we
send this information to the next
service
notice that the parent ID now has an ID
that was the span ID in the first
service and now the other service has a
new span ID which is different compared
to the first one but the trace ID
remains the same and this is how we're
able to get that directed acyclic graph
because we're able to correlate this
information and how it flows from the
you know this is the parent that's the
child or follows through
okay so next we have tags and logs both
of this they are not yet to span with
some contextual information tags would
typically apply to the whole span while
logs represent some events that happen
during the span execution right so and
something to keep in mind
tracing infrastructure does not track
causality between logged events the way
it keeps track of causality between
spans the relationships can always being
fired from the timestamp in logs now
you're probably asking so what can
tracing help me answer it the first
question that we found that was very
interesting was what services did I
request faster
this sounds like a very trivial question
but if you think about it let's say from
an organizational perspective you hire
new developers you have about two
hundred micro services and the mental
model of how a request heat goes through
the system it's much much harder to try
and explain than when it's just five
services because with five services you
can just say like yeah this is the how a
request will go through with 200 or 10x
that they need the mental model in your
head it becomes even harder and harder
but with distributed tracing it's much
much easier to try and explain that
because it's you can actually use the
visual the visual aspect of the
distributed tress to follow through on
how the request goes through the system
a second question is what occurred in
each service for given requests right
well when doing distributed tracing
we're collecting like highly
contextualized information and we
present this in traces and allow we can
be able to see what happened within each
and every service or we can log errors
we can attach logs and if one service
has all you can be able to use this to a
verdict bag or find out services that
are blocking or services that are in
your critical path that you need
to assign resources you can do
root-cause analysis with this type of
information - right
the next one is where did the error
happen in the coal chain so if you've
been on call most of the time there's a
service downstream that is the one
misbehaving but people up the chain are
still being paged and it's not it's not
a good feeling because it's probably
someone else's team's responsibility to
take care of that right we've
distributed tracing we can be able to
pinpoint which service down the call the
call chain is actually responsible for
that and traces what next so but I think
I've already talked about bottlenecks
and yes assigning resources or when a
services on a critical path you can
easily see that on their visualization
or the UI and if you need to assign more
resources to that you can be able to do
that
and lastly who should be paged in an
ideal world different teams would be
responsible for different services and
we need to be able to ping the right
team when their attention is needed on
something right no one wants to be paged
where they're having dinner with their
family okay so if dressing is so good
why isn't everyone using it I think
we're still there's still not enough
content out there in terms of education
or just published case studies on the
benefits of dressing I'm not trying to
diminish the efforts of a companies like
honeycomb and light step who have done
so much tremendous work in trying to
educate users but I think there's still
more that can be done and they still
room for improvement on you know
teaching and publishing case studies on
the benefits of this the next thing is
for a very long time most companies and
APM's
had their own implementations of
distributed dressing so once you bought
into someone's solution you were kind of
stuck with what they were doing with the
distributed tracing so this was a factor
that affected adoption or is
affects adoption at the moment but it's
getting better and better
picking back on that is with different
implementations that means that there's
a lot of inconsistency inconsistent
appears if this if the service provider
a is expensive and you'd like to switch
to service provider B then you have to
reinstall enter your application again
because the API is are probably
different and that was also a hindrance
in this lastly is a handle Fu's this is
a if service provider a has you know
implementation and is trying to there's
another service downstream that has the
user service provider B which is quite
actually very common in different teams
using different providers but work at
the same company so there's a lot of
issues with inconsistencies and handing
over the trace data to the next service
right now there's some work that is
already happening to try and you know
solve this and one of the the efforts is
is happening in a product called
or as an API called open telemetry so
what is open telemetry open telemetry is
a vendor-neutral API for instrumenting
distributed system it's a collective
effort from multiple organizations to
standardize on how to do distributed
tracing and enable everyone to play I
guess to play nice with each other yeah
and it's a single set of API is for
tracing they standardized on AP is for
you know context propagation exporters
to your back-end of your choice if you
already using some provider has a
back-end you can still continue doing
that and open now open telemetry
combines metrics and traces I think down
the line they might do logs and it has
integrations with the most popular web
and RFC's frameworks that everyone uses
right so where did open telemetry come
from right it's a result of you know
trying to merge two projects that
individually
were essentially doing the same thing
open tracing and open sisters of
entrancing was its underwear chlorinated
foundation and open senses opens was
open sourced by Google and open census
provides both metrics interesting while
I love interesting just provides a
tracing API but the tracing features for
both aim to provide a consistent way to
trace across different systems and
languages right so the goal of merging
the project were basically to create a
single instrumentation standard and
maintain functionality without including
every feature from both projects as
loosely they there's going to be a
backwards compatibility to anyone who's
still using up interesting or open
telemetry for a while so nothing to
worry about if you're already using
either of the it of the two right now
how do you do
instrumentation with open telemetry at
the moment there's two ways one using an
agent which is probably my preferred way
and to manually instrumenting your
application right with using an agent
I'd give an example if you're running on
the JVM you attach an agent when you
instantiate your application to your job
and it does bytecode manipulation it
does bytecode instrumentation and sends
this information to a particular tracer
right with the manual way you you know
get the dependency for the particular
tracer or the particular API that you
want you'd like to use and then you
manually instrument the specific
functions that you want to collect
information for and that could be a bit
tedious and it's the back and forth
between maybe off skies and developers
could be maybe developers don't want to
think I don't know could be harder than
just attaching an agent and collecting
that information
so how to get involved in open telemetry
one days I think there's maybe seven
languages that have been implemented so
far but the best place is to check the
github link and my favorite is open
telemetry Tuesday so if you'd like to
just catch up on what happened during
the week open telemetry Tuesday by Lee's
and I so Bell is probably the best place
to just catch up easily on that right so
yeah if you're a busy person and you'd
like yeah just shout out to them so the
project is still very young and they
still a lot that can be done please join
the mailing list please you know use the
or any existing SDKs and API is to
provide feedback to the team that is
working on it so that they can improve
on it now I'd like to show a demo of how
you can instrument an application so
this is an example application with two
services there's an order service and an
item service both services have separate
Redis instances as their primary data
store and when an order gets placed the
order check the order service contacts
the item service to check out the wish
of it if the items is requested I'll
stock or not and we want to instrument
this application yeah I'd be using open
tracing instead of open telemetry but
you can use either right so the first
step is to instantiate a tracer or
create a tracer if you look at line 128
I create a tracer I have a utility
function that does that for me it
basically just creates a instantiates
and returns an instance of jäger that
samples are 100% of the traces you're
probably wondering what does a tracer do
a tracer is responsible for tracking the
a tracer tress creates puns
gets a currently active spun this is
what would extract the
the span from my header when a request
comes in and would check whether there
is already an existing span or not I
yeah and the utility function is just
returns a an instance of a tracer now
you don't have to use Yaeger there's all
these different traces and probably more
that I'm forgetting that you can use
already using within your company if
you're looking for something that is
hosted honeycomb band light stuff and
data dog New Relic
or they're probably a good place to look
at if you're looking for something open
sources Yaeger Zipkin Apache sky walking
and many others that would come after
open telemetry becomes stable and so I'm
using golang as the language to just
show the examples but yeah since we'll
be there's going to be a lot of
functionality that is repeated so I just
abstracted this to a middleware that
would track every request that comes
into the system
and yeah so at line 45 we when a request
comes into the system we first check the
headers to see if there's any stress
related headers a came in with a request
if if we don't get a request then we if
we don't get the Tres headers then we
create we create headers and inject that
into the context now this is going to be
used when we start instrumenting our
handlers for instance they get item they
get item handler in line 207 they're
open tracing dot stats one from context
so it returns a span with an operation
name using any spun found within the
context that we've passed him as a child
of or yeah as a parent here and I'm
using Yaga and any information about
yaga yaga was
it's a distributed tracing platform open
sourced by know inspired by DAPA and
open Zipkin just created in 2015 and
donated to the cloud native foundation
it's compliant with both open tracing
and open sensors support multiple
storage and it's compatible with Kafka
if you're doing a lot of because you
could end up generating a lot of traces
and you'd need some sort of back
pressure management Kafka would probably
be perfect for that all right so let me
just switch to the example
so this is what the Jaeger UI looks like
the application is already running at
the back and you can be able to from
this blob run be able to get all the
different services that are running you
can look at individual operations if you
want and click on find traces probably
nothing with that
who
just one moment
so this is an example of how a tres
would look like P this is the roots one
gives you an idea of how long the tress
took and the methods that were called
all the services that worked the many
went through same thing because they
order much more interesting so the roots
one would tell you how long their
request took if you click on a spine you
can be able to get more information on
what happened the processes and details
that you could use for resource actually
assigning resources to stuff and see if
I can get
there we go
so yeah like I mentioned this is how we
create the tracer
sorry about that yeah
[Music]
and the Trece middleware and the utility
function to just help create Jaeger
return an instances of the tracer when
we got to know yeah
and then you can attach the middleware
to trace each and every incoming request
so and how to I guess just deploy that I
have a simple llamo that puts everything
together and just do a look a compose up
and that's it so I'll open the up the
flow up for questions in case anyone has
questions thank you for your time
[Applause]
glad
so I think you can start as one person
and then use that opportunity to sell to
the rest of the team on the benefits of
doing that because you I think going to
the rest of the team might be an uphill
battle that and without any evidence of
the benefits of it it might be a hard
sell to that right yeah
so they appear my chains I don't know
how best to answer that question but if
you're okay with API changing because
you maybe have to recompile under
instrument every other time you pull in
a new dependency then that's fine you
can use it yeah yeah
there's many I don't know where to begin
yeah we can talk yeah the back yeah so I
picked that ties to sampling because
some based on how you sample traces some
people might just want to keep wondering
one trace out of 100 because they
essentially look the same but the
solutions that can do 100% store all the
traces and you can be able to get
insights after a couple of days or weeks
if you if you'd like and this is
probably is you can configure that
traces such as Jager to sample one
hundred percent o2 sample one percent if
you'd like I don't know if I'm answering
the question
if in if it's in the same service yeah
it's the same trace yeah yes these I
think there's efforts in putting
together a JavaScript tracing library
that you can start generating request
from the front-end going back to the
server so yeah it's possible yeah
so that highly depends on what you
really want to instrument you could if
you're collecting too much traces then
you might see the overhead oh my you
might see might notice that there is
some performance issues with the amount
of data you're collecting so you there's
probably better ways or you want to find
the functions or places you really want
to trace and then start with that and
then probably with time you can keep on
adding if you feel like you need more
visibility into what's up what's
happening
but can you just speak out loudly
so that's a very good question so the
question is about context propagation -
if you're going through multiple
services right yeah so you might lose
context if all the services don't buy
into the idea and it's still so you need
to one get everyone who's involved in
all the different services to buy into
the idea for that - particularly happen
so I really have no idea how best to
answer that if not everyone buys into
the idea because you might have places
in the call graph where there is
literally nothing for correlation yeah
name of open telemetry yes just figure
out how to use this thing
yeah any other questions
inside of a cantilever paper yeah
so I'm what's the question yeah it's
common so there's these so they these
efforts to implement traces for popular
RPC frameworks databases and so you can
get this out of the box from your my
sequel instance or Postgres or whatever
provider and I think the traces will be
correlated or there'll be a lot of
causality so you can be able to do that
yeah okay any other questions all right
thank you so much and have a great rest
of the day